the
[Music]
of all time this is taco 1986 and this
is the best team in america right here
[Applause]
we're ready to make the best tacos for
you being a taquero you have to look
good smell good and feel good
there's no one better than me i'm pretty
there's couples in america
tell your friends your family
sit back relax and enjoy the show guys
[Applause]
welcome to another episode of tacos
contour we got a very special one
especially because we're doing something
a little different mr bobby lee will be
joining me he thinks we're going to eat
tacos
we have some other plants we're going to
put ourselves in the shoes of one of the
best taqueros in la around the world mr
jorge here at 1986 and we're going to
see what it's like to be a taquero so
we'll see hopefully he doesn't yell at
us too much
of course i'm gonna yell oh there he is
hey guys i just i just brought this to
make sure he doesn't [ __ ] up let's get
to it
[Music]
what's up dude dude thanks for being
here hey we're no we're beyond these
yeah we do these right yes bobby thank
you for being here we have a great
we have a great episode
and um
the guy came out the owner yeah and he
he claimed it's the greatest in the
world yeah so he's kind of like the
michael jordan of tacos yes he's the
greatest taquero in the world and he's
like
taquero
i said it right he said it right here
thank you we're gonna step into the
shoes of what it's like to be one of the
best taquetos in la okay you down
i have to be
so yeah let's do it all right cool let's
do it
your mustache man oh thank you i love
your lunch to grow that uh
35 years yeah 43.
mustache you're late homie
first day on the job okay change now or
change right not right here wherever
you go
the comedy business is not doing good if
you can make a beautiful taco we can
talk partnerships okay first thing cool
cool we gotta run it down from making a
tortilla chopping up all the meats
making sure you can slice this amazing
avobada taco and if you can do this
you might be
a majority partner i don't know so bob
you gotta show me those two is that he
does this kissy thing a lot though he
does a kissy thing a lot so yeah so
we're gonna clock him every time he does
that let's get suited up oh boy oh boy
oh boy
you know what i love about already um
i'm sure the cameras aren't um
everything's clean thank you mr bobby
lee yeah i mean that's i love that lady
this is mr bobby lee he's going to be
working with us today i'm part owner
part owner now
you're fired
not cool bobby
guys
welcome to your first day at taco's 1986
thank you thank you
first we start off by greeting the
customers here we sell pork steak
mushroom and chicken tacos they all come
with onions cilantro guacamole and salsa
okay can i ask you something you can ask
me when the customers come in do i lie
and say i'm mexican but i'm just really
we're gonna we're gonna change your name
all right what is it we're you're gonna
go from bobby lee yeah to bobby pulido
that means bobby polished oh okay bobby
polito so you're gonna be what about
cochino is that a mommy coach
i got the best tacos in america young
lady what can i get you uh
what do you want hey
[Applause]
thanks man thank you so much thank you
that's mr bobby lee right here
you always got to say we're the greatest
you're always going to be
well we're there okay okay hey i'm bobby
pulido i'm the greatest people leader in
america i'm bobby polito
grammy nominated grammy winner
everything
a little less a little less a little
less
you say you're hungry i'm hungry so what
what about this you gotta wait till your
break
you can't just come in here and you know
like start eating you know like
hey jesus here note to self never put
your ear up against the scorching hot
adobada trompo fry food [ __ ] hurry
dude oh man [ __ ] that's hot
mexican gold right here you caught this
right here yeah it turns into gold okay
boom so you have to roll
you roll it you roll it look at that can
i try yeah okay
okay okay all right we go oh [ __ ]
let me try
you're doing it wrong man here we go
this is mine no no no no no no
no no no no no
no no no no no i'm not hungry no no no
no no no excuse what's your name
alejandra bobby
politis
so what i want to ask you right can i
get a hug
so um how did you make the circular
because mine comes out flat might like
my face
is that cut that part
that's racist that's racist you gotta do
it's your turn all right step over here
step over here thank you so much you're
in timeout i'm so sorry that's my third
i've never gotta roll in tap man
oh he's
just throwing away money here jesus
thank you so much i'm glad your comedy
is doing good i'm glad but here you know
we're in the middle of a pandemic that's
pretty good dude that's really good for
a comedian
perfectionist man
we can't work under these conditions oh
yes you can yeah and you will
now can you do this
can you do this boom
can i
do that catch it
absolutely not
yeah
yeah i can do it so boom all right you
come in here all right and if they say
contolo can you say
that means onion cilantro yeah yeah
where's my tortilla he's doing the kissy
thing is that fresh guacamole and salsa
you gotta do this okay boom that's half
an ounce of guacamole
excuse me you gotta tap the trumpo right
tap it
you gotta be nice
there we go grab that throne
tap it
you're doing it wrong
it's my first time okay all right just
give me a second all right i'm so sorry
i got angry i'm so sorry
anger management here we got an anger
management guy
anger you're doing it wrong
you gotta you gotta back up
that's a lot of oil i know dude
because you're present nope oh my god
almost carved major freaking over here
damn
ramsay we're not navy seals we're
working at the taco bell
the tortilla is cold can i give it a try
yeah okay
i think i got it bobby
bobby
we got this i think we got it oh he's
kind of getting it oh jesus machete over
here heavy
boom what the [ __ ] is this oh that's hot
i gotta eat something okay hey we're not
gonna eat this i'm just gonna eat this
mr bobby polito i'm gonna make it for
you perfectly you're gonna stand right
here i'm gonna stand right here what
kind would you like steak chicken
mushroom more pork handsome uh okay i'd
like a pastor
okay man
man i said it yeah this is
so can you say
it's our version of the crispy taco
please tell the world how great i am oh
so delicious my god it's so good so hold
on the greatest you have one position
two people applied so far who's in the
running is it bobby or is it me
i don't know i think i'm going to have
to go with mr bobby pulido really he's
got
it thank you so much thank you
all right we're going to put our skills
to the test from beginning to end bobby
all right all right i'll do it this is
the taco 1986 olympics okay let's do it
all right what's up man remember
how can i help you um
this is my first time here your first
time here so do you like beef do you
like pork do you like mushrooms
hey hey you like chimichangas hey i do i
do we don't have them
what do you expect from us i'll just get
a car and saw taco karnassada sounds
good for me what do they want all right
bobby two outside of tacos coming right
up
to us a lot of tacos let's see bobby
let's see you do it bobby that's the
perfect scoop food scoop okay
uh-huh very good is that enough we're
very good yes that's perfect that's a
perfect portion onion and salad do you
use
yeah use your hands your hands don't be
different
nice and clean hands boom boom
a little salsa
oh look at that guacamole or not smear
it's a smear
nope nope what do you mean boom like it
was mayonnaise homie
no no it's fine it's fine bobby knight
god i'm not on a basketball team man why
is he yelling i don't know but we got
customers okay okay okay we can play we
need one more one more what's up with it
right here bobby
i'll get another one going get another
paper this is not how i taught you bobby
i didn't teach you how to do it like
this
i didn't teach you i didn't teach you
how to do it like okay
sorry i'm sorry it's taking us a little
longer
where's the paper come on the tortilla
is getting cold man okay
all right i've never seen
bobby get out of the way get up i got
this god damn it [ __ ] you don't even
roll him
can i get another tortilla please sorry
to keep you waiting everything he tells
me to do i do it and he yells at me it's
like it's crazy
that's how you do it you got to be
fast here you got to be efficient you
got to be sexy
i'm the greatest i get of all time can i
get it i'm the greatest second of all
you're the grizz
of all time you're the greatest yeah
yeah you're the greatest yeah here give
this to jesus okay here you go jesus
thank you sir thank you so much sorry
for the for the win
have a great day
come see us again all right here we go
we got a customer bobby hello we are
meninos
welcome to the best tacos in america man
attention
welcome to tacos 1986. i'm sergeant
polita
polito
what would you like
why is this coming out because it's
online orders yeah sorry
oh you need those bobby these are the
tickets oh you need those don't throw
them away
okay
i got it
[Applause]
all right
that doesn't make is right but
it doesn't seem right but it's 30
dollars
take me with you
take me with you where are you going
i don't know what is going on i have no
idea what anyone else is cilantro all
your cilantro okay here we go onion
cilantro salsa guacamole that's the
first taco we're killing it we're
killing it it's a smear it doesn't i i
have my own style i drop i don't smear
all right when you make the tacos you
smear it this is what i want oh it
doesn't matter i'm this is what i want
can you give me a little bit more of
that let's go another taco let's go this
looks beautiful this looks beautiful
bobby lee let's go
why are you shaking
because i think we're both a little
scared we were scared
give me the give me that
all right put it in your hand please put
it outside
give me the meat give me the meat this
is wrong paper
we need this one
he's mexican for sure doc
he's got it all right here we go your
hand is your hand oh yeah come on come
on hurry hurry all right all right he's
outside
why are you looking for him here good
job all right
yeah i'm getting i don't think he's
gonna make it man bobby i know he's your
friend you have oh
watch him watch him watch him watch
tomorrow morning that's exhausting
that's like hard this is like really
hard to do oh
we did three tacos and she did seven in
one hit this is harder than i thought it
was gonna be
like you guys really [ __ ] up my
trombone
like for real
i just want to say that anybody who
walks in through these stores they might
have a little insecurity a little maybe
i'm not good enough for this but i
believe in every single person
that walks in through these stores just
like i believe in you guys you guys are
going to come with me to paris to japan
with you
i'm not i am not going anywhere with you
my friend all right all right number one
all right i didn't i'm sorry the food is
great number one the tacos right one
through ten the tacos a tent i told you
i'm the greatest it's great right the
environment in terms of cleanliness
which i always look for attend
everything with [ __ ] and span right
your greatest management
and ownership
meth energy
that's all i can say it's like a carney
it's like a carney meth energy like i
said you guys did great okay all right i
think uh bobby you greeted every
customer you looked at them in the eye
you spoke the truth you said i don't
know what adobata means but it's
delicious you have uh no spanish skills
but you greeted everybody perfectly so
wherever it is that you go you're gonna
do great greetings for the opportunity
yeah yeah jesus you're a great taqueto
you're a natural i think uh
i think you should stick with us
then move into management position
yeah then you can be an assistant's
assistant
which is my my niece you know
beer assistant now
here's my question to you being the
greatest
uh is making tacos harder yes under your
control yes
it is harder because i want to jump into
comedy man i don't know if i uh please
do
please do
i would love would you be like you to
come to the comedy club right and i
would love to berate you
when you're on stage for race yeah i
will heckle you right and i will tell
you let me tell you i can help you
you're not doing it right right and that
you're a failure i've never said that
you did it to me all right i did not
call you a failure i did not say that i
said that
i understand your weaknesses and i can
bring out the best in you okay when
you're on sale you're weak
that that should be funny am i gonna get
we gave it a shot much respect you're
not going anywhere man
you're a tall handsome taquero we don't
get much of those uh don't call me for a
while
i i'm so sorry i don't know what we're
gonna do this episode you did all right
i lost a good friend but i gained a
position here in 1986 as an assistant to
his niece
oh and by the way you know how many
times you did the kissy thing in the
span of one hour
23 times
this is what this is
thousands
[Music]
hello my name is jesus i'm the host of
tacos contolo and don't forget to like
and subscribe you can watch more right
here hurry watch another episode before
your boss comes in and you get fired for
real this time